hallo leute heute haben wir uns
vorgenommen wieder eine einfache episode
zu drehen
und zwar werden wir dafür ein bisschen
ruhe spazieren und gegenstände suchen
und die für euch beschreiben
wir hoffen dass dieser worte helfen wird
beim deutsch lernen viel spaß
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was ist das das ist ein blatt das ist
das blatt was sehe ich
ich sehe ein blatt ich sehe das blatt
was ist das das sind blätter
das sind die blätter was sie ich sehe
blätter ich sehe die blätter was mache
ich mit dem blatt ich lasse das blatt
fliegen
was mache ich mit den blättern
ich lasse die blätter fliegen
was ist das das ist ein scooter das ist
der scooter was sehe ich
ich sehe einen scooter ich sehe den
scooter was mache ich fahre mit einem
scooter
ich fahre mit dem scooter
was ist passiert
ich hatte einen unfall mit dem scooter
was ist das das ist ein stuhl
das ist der stuhl was sehe ich
ich sehe einen stuhl ich sehe den stuhl
was mache ich setze mich auf den stuhl
was ist das das ist ein tisch das ist
der tisch was sehe ich
ich sehe einen tisch ich sehe den tisch
was mache ich setze mich an den tisch
was ist das das ist ein schirm das ist
der schirm was sehe ich
ich sehe einen schirm
ich sehe den schirm was mache ich
ich stelle mich unter den schirm
was ist das das ist ein mülleimer
das ist der mülleimer was sehe ich
ich sehe einen mülleimer
ich sehe den mülleimer was mache ich
ich werfe ein taschentuch in den
mülleimer
was ist das das ist ein tor das ist das
tor
was sehe ich ich sehe ein tor
ich sehe das tor was mache ich ich öffne
das tor und gehe durch das tor
was ist das das ist eine laterne
das ist die laterne was sehe ich
ich sehe eine laterne
ich sehe die laterne was mache ich lehne
mich an die laterne
was ist das das ist eine fahrrad das ist
das fahrrad was sehe ich
ich sehe ein fahrrad
ich sehe das fahrrad was mache ich setze
mich auf das fahrrad und fahre los
was ist das das ist ein stein
das ist der stein was sehe ich
ich sehe einen stein
ich sehe den stein was mache ich stelle
mich auf den stein
was ist das das ist ein kleiner stein
das ist der kleine stein was sehe ich
ich sehe einen kleinen stein
ich sehe den kleinen stein
was mache ich werfe den stein
was ist das das ist ein pfeiler
das ist der pfeiler was sehe ich
ich sehe einen pfeiler
ich sehe den pfeiler was mache ich ich
gehe um den pfeiler
was ist das das ist ein kürbis
das ist der kürbis was sehe ich
ich sehe einen kürbis
ich sehe den kürbis was will ich damit
machen
ich will etwas für halloween daraus
machen dass man unsere gegenstände für
heute und wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr
deutsch lernen wollt könnt ihr gerne
unsere apps ittling benutzen und ihren
wortschatz noch erweitern
bis nächste woche